I've said repeatedly that America
doesn't torture and I'm going to make
sure that we don't torture amongst
liberals libertarians and even some
conservatives it's been considered hope
that Barack Obama would radically
transformed George Bush's policies
regarding the war on terror and on
certain issues the new administration is
the Liberty measured amount of change
probably close the detention facility at
Guantanamo consistent with the national
security and foreign policy interests of
the United States and interests of
Justice I your Bible but we're Obama's
executive orders banning torture and
closing down the prison at Guantanamo
Bay just a head-fake with the design to
placate a certain segment of his base
while actually continuing or even
expanding many of Bush's terrorism
policies there's ample evidence to
support such a reading for instance in a
move that stunned and disappointed many
Democrats Obama recently sided with the
bush administration's policy of not
allowing detainees the Bagram prison and
Afghanistan constitutional protections
the recently appointed director of
national intelligence Admiral Dennis
Blair enraged Obama supporters when he
refused during his confirmation hearing
to call waterboarding torture if this
wasn't enough CIA director Leon Panetta
has been connected to rendition cases
during his time as Bill Clinton's White
House chief of staff and Human Rights
Watch spokesman recently told Eli Lake
of the Washington Times the Clinton
policy and practice meant torture what
we know is that Leon Panetta in his
testimony for his nomination hearings
left not only open the prospect of
rendition but said that the CIA would
continue the practice of rendition two
countries for trial and for justice and
he indicated that there would be
assurances that would be given to make
sure that prisoners were treated
humanely but that falls somewhat short
of the standard the ACLU another civil
liberties groups want the rendition
issue is really unclear we asked
director of the ACL used DC legislative
office Caroline fredriksen for her take
on the new administration's war on
terror policies when high-level
officials say that they're going to rely
on the assurances of foreign governments
that's not comforting that's not that's
not good enough because that's clearly
exactly what the Bush administration did
in a case against a Boeing subsidiary
that flew prisoners to be questioned
abroad the Obama Justice Department has
fallen back in the very same state
secrets policy used by the bush
administration hoping to prevent the
release of evidence related to
ordinary renditions the Obama
administration through its justice
department is saying that that case
cannot move forward the exact same
position taken by the Bush
administration because even discussing
these issues in court would make our
national security weaker and while
Guantanamo will be closed within the
year there is little indication of just
what Obama plans to do with the 245
prisoners remaining in a facility and
what will become of the so-called black
sites those secret prisons the CIA uses
for interrogation well there were a
number of ambiguities and executive
orders that President Obama issued
pretty much his second day in office and
one of those is dealing with the
so-called black sites he suggested that
they would no longer be used as
permanent sites but can they be used for
short-term detention transition sites
that's still an open question and he
left that to a committee to evaluate we
think that's really troubling because I
don't know what a temporary detention
facility is to be anything from a limo
from a yacht owned by a friend of the
CIA to a safe house will remain open
which strongly suggests as I as I've
written and others have written the
policy of rendition will continue in
some degree for those who supported
President Obama in hopes of a
significant deviation from Bush
administration war on terror policy
these first few months have been a
massive disappointment well he might be
a progressive Democrat on economic
issues he will not be a code pink or
move on president when it comes to
foreign policy Leon Panetta Admiral
Blair Vice President Biden have
acknowledged there's a class of
prisoners at Guantanamo of the 243 that
will neither be tried in a civilian
court in America or sent to a foreign
court or released from jail well there
have been significant differences such
as the closing of Guantanamo and the
outlawing of torture there's much that's
either a continuation of Bush policies
like increased drone strikes on Pakistan
or a slight modification of them like
rendition and rights for terror
detainees sure we're only a few months
into this administration and there's
much that could happen in the next four
years but for now it appears that on the
economy the Obama administration will be
Bush on steroids and the war on terror
he's going to be busch light for reason
TV I'm Michael Moynihan